[Música]
Oye, me deportaron con un chico que tenía
como 20 21 años, no lo sé y me preguntó, oye, ¿
es difícil aprender español? Le dije, ¿
qué quieres decir con que
no hablas español, simplemente,
nadie?  mejor aprende español rápido
[Risas]
sí, lo estaban deportando no hablaba
nada de español ¿
cómo va a sobrevivir? Quiero
decir, como dicen repatriar, cómo
te van a repatriar a un
país en el que nunca has vivido, ¿
cómo es eso?
la obra toca tierra durante la noche como
categoría cuatro en texas y
luisiana la tormenta explota
transformadores dejando a 400 000 personas
sin electricidad a esta hora
mientras charles watson vive en
tierra en port arthur texas que ha
estado al oeste del centro de la
tormenta charles el sol que se pone
hermoso cerca de la pared él está aquí mientras
dribble cabrera gana para nueva york una
carrera de tres
[Aplausos]
me siento como en casa
no
[Música] ¿
no parece como si nunca hubiera
desempaquetado?
no estoy cómodo aquí
mentalmente no estoy aquí
físicamente no estoy allí estoy
en el limbo estoy en estoy en tierra de nadie
estoy en la línea
estoy literalmente en línea
mi nombre es richard avila
Soy un veterano militar
criado en el este de Los Ángeles, California,
viví en los Estados Unidos toda mi vida y
finalmente me deportaron.
Perdí la vida. Perdí mi trabajo. Perdí mi
auto. Perdí a mi novia.
Perdí a mi familia. Quiero decir, sabes,
eso es mucho.  cosas para llevar
[Música]
cuanto más viva aquí en tijuana,
simplemente no es
saludable
[Música]
gracias por llamar a los prestamistas de Liberty Cash
mi nombre es Richard ¿Puedo darme
tu número de seguro social para
ayudarte mejor? Por favor,
sí, Richard
[Música]
gracias 461-  5729 entonces lori um,
podrías calificar para
un préstamo de seis mil dólares, ¿
vale?, ¿sería hoy? ¿
Estás diciendo que necesitas
financiamiento hoy?
Sí, eso es lo que estoy diciendo.
Estoy trabajando aquí en Tijuana en el mismo
campo que la mayoría de  los deportados
recibimos llamadas de los estados unidos, de
hecho trabajo para un centro de llamadas que
otorga préstamos, está
bien, una vez que seas aprobado, decidiremos
para cuánto eres elegible.
Muchas gracias, Richard
[Aplausos],
estas compañías quieren angloparlantes
y yo.  Necesito un trabajo
gracias por llamar a los prestamistas de Liberty Cash.
Mi nombre es Richard.
Es irónico porque Estados Unidos
nos deporta a México y luego usa nuestras
habilidades por mucho menos dinero.
No lo dije por ella. No sé cuándo será
la próxima vez.  Voy a verla mientras
este oficial del ejército estadounidense lucha por su
país. Su madre es expulsada.
Ella fue deportada esta mañana después de
varios intentos de revocar esa
decisión cuando realmente
nos dijeron que todavía se le negaba que
ya lo era.  en tijuana su hijo me dice que su
reunión de inmigración solo duró unos 30
minutos y luego se fue ella ahora está en
méxico
esto es
[Música]
es [
Música]
juan
[Música]
te extraño
iremos a ver tu miércoles
un día, no dos  días
puedes venir a ver iremos
a ti mil días
[Música]
vale
mi bebe vienes a verme no puedo
realmente
me amaste
si pero no puedo ir
contigo méxico es  muy lejos
[Música]
universidad
vamos a tomar asiento aquí mismo en
el primer escritorio está bien,
sí, por favor, adelante y toma asiento, ¿
cómo estás hoy? Estoy bien, muy
bien, excelente,
entonces.  Estoy muy bien, gracias. Esta es la
primera vez que solicitas con nosotros. Correcto,
sí, ¿cuánto tiempo has estado en
Tijuana durante 40 días? ¿Sabes
algo que tenga que ver con los
centros de llamadas? ¿Alguna vez te has familiarizado
con lo que hacemos en llamadas?  centros,
entonces, ¿
qué tipo de trabajo hiciste en los
Estados Unidos?
Hora para el trabajo.
Tengo
mi negocio inmobiliario
durante
25 años. Bien, ¿
tienes alguna pregunta sobre cómo
funcionaban los centros de llamadas? No. ¿
Cuánto tiempo estuviste viviendo en los Estados Unidos?
como 20 nah 34 años 34 años casa como
desde los tres años sí como 34 años
ok [
Aplausos]
adelante y cuéntame un poco sobre
tu experiencia laboral bueno siempre he
trabajado en un restaurante así que realmente no
tengo ninguna  Me gusta la experiencia Me gusta
Hacia el tipo de trabajo Causas Está
bien, ¿
qué te trae a un centro de llamadas?
Sí, entré. Perdí mis papeles, así que me
deportaron. ¿
Cuánto tiempo estuvo residiendo en los Estados Unidos?
Años
Seis años y cuánto tiempo ha estado  estuve en
tijuana por una semana y tres días
comencé a reírme y pensé: "oh, tengo
papeles, te equivocaste de persona, se les
ocurrió mi foto,
este eres tú, ¿no?", te van a
deportar, ¿estás casado?, ¿tienes
hijos?, sí.  Estoy casado, vale, tengo
tres, tres hijos, tres varones y una
hija,
pero tengo dos nietos, un nieto y un
amigo puede interponerse en el camino, vale, entonces, sí, ¿
están
todos en los Estados Unidos? Sí, hoy todos están en los Estados Unidos.
en la mañana que llegué en el autobús,
sí, estaba nervioso, estaba peor, hacía
frío pero estaba sudando, estaba como hombre, ¿a
dónde voy a ir? [Música] como si todos los centros de llamadas te preguntaran dónde estás ubicado, pero tú
Nunca voy a decir que voy a mantener a T1
frente a la pared, eso está ahí, cierto,
sucedió chicos, sucedió antes de
confiar en ellos,
hay muchos nombres en el sitio web,
sí, está bien, no te preocupes, tenemos esa portada, soy  Te
enseñaré el conocimiento de las flores,
eso es lo que necesito aprender.
Estamos orgullosos de ofrecer una selección en línea
de ramos de margaritas. Nuestras mejores
margaritas gerber llegan en una variedad
de tonos vibrantes. Si notas que
cada vez que intentamos convencer a un cliente,
usemos adjetivos.
Nuestra gerber.  ramo de margaritas y un animado
rayo de sol para hacer de este día un día en el que
su destinatario especial nunca olvidará.
Usamos las emociones del cliente para
convencerlos de que
no siempre va a funcionar, muchachos, pero la
otra cosa es que las ventas adicionales no son una opción,
es una instrucción que
recibí aquí.  6 todavía estaba oscuro y
a lo largo de los años estaba bien, ¿estoy en el
lugar correcto? No, al menos no me voy a
perder
porque eso es lo que estaba diciendo.
Estaba en el autobús. Estaba como preguntarles a
todos. Disculpen
Canadá
[Música]
entonces
[Aplausos]
[Música]
extranjera
si no eres fuerte yo no seré fuerte
tú eres mi columna vertebral [
Música]
qué diablos
ah
[Música]
hola sí señora, mi nombre es Richard  Dean, te
llamo desde los prestamistas de Liberty Cash,
solo estamos interesados ​​en los últimos 30
días de tus transacciones, ¿
estás conduciendo?
No, ese es mi fan. No sabes, el aire acondicionado del pobre
te voy a poner en un breve agujero.
Sean uh Rozier.
Sí,
sí, tengo
mucha práctica
con todas las llamadas,
sí, está
bien, Sean, ¿puedes verificar tu cumpleaños
por mí? Por favor,
hablo con chicos que tienen como 80
años y algunos niños que tienen como 21 años.  vieja
[Música]
algunas señoras que suenan bien, ¿sabes?, sabes que
tu banco ha sido verificado. Genial, lo hicimos.
Chandra
[Música]
uh, es como un escape.
Firmé eléctricamente
el documento del préstamo. Lo siento mucho por
esto, está bien.  bien, no te preocupes,
ese es mi trabajo
antes de la segunda taza de café. Siento
lo mismo.
Realmente me aleja de donde estoy,
pero después de todo eso, después del trabajo, la
televisión,
como dije, me siento como si estuviera en un  jaula,
si vas a salir al agua y
estoy hablando de la base para tal vez
remar temprano en kayak, hacer remo,
lo que quieras hacer temprano esta
mañana, absolutamente es bueno,
Sheena, que no haga viento
[Música]
[Música], ¿
verdad?  Ahora
[Música]
Llegué a los Estados Unidos cuando
tenía un año. Fui feliz, tuve una infancia normal
y
mis problemas comenzaron en el ejército y
en
Vietnam cuando mi primo murió.
Probablemente tenía 15,
tal vez 60,
y él fue asesinado en Vietnam.  Así que
ya estaba pensando
que tan pronto como tenga edad suficiente me
uniré al ejército, iré a Vietnam y
mataré a muchos vietnamitas.
Eso es lo que estaba pensando.
Realmente hay solo una gran historia. El
padrastro de Estados Unidos.
Yo mismo estoy enojado, tenía 17 años cuando me alisté
hasta ahora, mi mamá comenzó a llorar y
todo tomó un par de fotografías de
mi papá, mi papá estaba muy orgulloso
después de eso,
Pelosi y Chuck Schumer se dirigieron a
la Casa Blanca para una reunión programada previamente.  El
primer año
estuve
um
comprometido con el uniforme, la bandera
y nuestra misión,
fue una guerra totalmente inútil
[Música]
empezamos a usar el pelo largo,
no puedes usarlo, no puedes usar bigote
más largo que aquí y
la gente los está usando.  Hasta aquí
sabes que fue como si ya no me importara un [ __ ]
y
fue entonces cuando probé la heroína por primera vez,
fue el comienzo del fin de mi
vida normal
[Música] [
Música]
oh
extranjera
[Música]
a
el presidente
[Música]
tiene
extranjera
[Música]
este lugar es interesante eh, es algo así
como lo que esperaba ver en las
favelas brasileñas,
excepto el siglo pasado,
oh Dios mío [
Música]
[Música]
solo ve a youtube y aprende una nueva
receta
[Música]
qué estamos haciendo eso está mal
es
[Música]
um
gracias por venir guarda flores este
es sergio en qué puedo ayudarte
[  Música]
uh, está llamando a la tienda principal, señor, uh,
y ¿qué es ella? Eso significa que es una
unidad corporativa de 300, señor, ¿puedo darme su
número de teléfono, por favor, el
número de teléfono de la señorita Lucia, uh, de la señorita Mary, en caso de que mi conducción tenga que
disculparme, de
dónde soy?
Estamos ubicados en 300 Corporate Estamos
ubicados en 300 Corporate Drive Center en
Mawa, Nueva Jersey, pero la entrega nunca es un
problema para nosotros. Tenemos 20 000
talleres afiliados para trabajar con nosotros, señor. ¿
Puedo comunicarme con su teléfono del
condado?  Estamos en el número 60 y
tenemos algunos 60 superiores aquí también, así que después de las
9 a. m. continuaremos, comenzaremos
a calentarnos mucho y alcanzaremos los 80 grados
alrededor de las 10 a. m.
san diego
[Música]
chiquitas
sí
[Música]  ]
pasaporte por favor
[Música]
¿tienes una identificación pasaporte por favor
um [
Música]
entonces [
es
[Música]
oh
extranjero
[Música]
por qué querrías que el auto diga señor
feliz
San Valentín
[Música]
[Aplausos]
oh, está bien, perfecto, déjame escuchar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
puedo
esperar
a que
[Música]
te vea esta noche.
No puedo esperar a verte esta noche. Está bien,
perfecto,
sí,
podrías dejar que descanse en paz. uh, amada tía,
tío, quiero decir, uh, es  una señora lo
siento, me disculpo por eso um tenemos
globos tenemos un
cumpleaños difícil de alcanzar tenemos ositos de peluche um
tienes lápiz y papel ella puede
escribir el pedido número
una venta más
[Música] en la que
nos vamos a centrar  aub, a tu aov le está
yendo muy bien, lo
sé porque eres nuevo, cursi,
pero sé que puedes hacerlo
[Música]
No creo que
César me dé aob, muchacho,
tu conversión es lo suficientemente saludable, cierto, dame
aobi, está bien, centrémonos en aov.  gris de
lujo
qué es qué es uh qué manera de
intentar perfumar oh flores para lo que sea está
bien que tengamos uh el sueño de la Toscana
esto esto y aquello oh está bien, vayamos con
ese recomendaría su
grado de lujo porque tienen más sopladores
florece yadda yadda
está bien, está bien,
centrémonos en aob sí, eso
es correcto señor, está bien, tengo una
pregunta, señor, ¿le gustaría poner una
cinta a juego en su arreglo de
hoy?
Señora, está bien, ¿y
si fuera por la hija?
Ella no quiere gastar dinero en la
hija, sí,
recuerda que tenemos que golpearlo con emoción,
hombre, la emoción
me hace llorar
[Música]
después de mi servicio militar
durante los siguientes 30 años, estaba en una niebla.
[Música]
Estaba sumido en mi adicción.
Me arrestaron por robar una tienda
para conseguir dinero para comprar drogas.
Puedes argumentar
lo que quieras sobre por qué me deportaste,
pero por donde lo mires,
estás deportando a un estadounidense que
preferirías.  Estar en México que en los
Estados Unidos, como dije, si pudiera
regresar, solo querría regresar y
visitar
un fin de semana a la semana y regresaría. Ya
no vivo en los Estados Unidos. Ya sabes,
hay una palabra.  Se llama sueño americano,
eso es todo, es un sueño,
puedes perseguir el sueño mexicano aquí,
por aquí,
me siento legal aquí, ¿sabes?
Si
pudieras vivir legalmente en los Estados Unidos, sí,
vivirías en México,
trabajarías y vivirías en México,
no.  ¿No
habría razón para pensar en ello?
Holmes, por supuesto, no, no, amigo, espera, espera,
por supuesto que no. Estoy pensando
en eso, yo
personalmente ahora mismo, que se jodan los Estados Unidos.
Estoy bien aquí,
sí, una
buena ducha caliente.  una bañera en una
bañera una habitación no una ducha una bañera o
al menos una hora
imagina
sí
abajo
hay muchas cosas que das por
sentado allí
imagina cruzar y luego tener a alguien
esperando la tuya
porque hay una carretera justo ahí
sí la hay  He visto autos, sí, yo también
aquí,
pero te
apuesto que hay un punto allí,
oh sí, eso es lo que diré, hay un
punto, tiene que haber algo
allí o allí, mm-hmm, así es.
No va a ser tan fácil,
no,
imagina si fuera así de fácil,
estaré allí,
hey, Miami,
wow, sí,
cruzo, recojome
[Música]
regresa por cuánto tiempo, no, para siempre,
sí, luego nos dejaron, tenemos papeles,
tenemos papeles.  Recuperamos nuestros papeles,
sí,
somos libres,
vale, escucha, se
supone que debemos poder estar de acuerdo en no estar
de acuerdo porque lo que estás diciendo es
correcto, no, no, no, no estoy diciendo que
no me estoy metiendo contigo.  No, sabes, no estoy tratando de
decirte qué hacer, vale, pero
quiero decir, ¿
realmente preferirías vivir en México
que en los Estados Unidos
y ahora mismo en este momento, pero
por qué sí,
pero por qué quiero decir?  Quiero decir, solo estoy
tratando de entender por qué
todos mis sobrinos y naciones desde el
principio me llamaban tío
Richie,
no sé qué, tío Richie, Richie,
Richie, está
bien, y sabes, me encanta que
simplemente sean.  solo una línea a través de
la arena están justo al otro lado
de la frontera, ya
sabes, pero
no puedo estar bien,
eso es lo que realmente me duele, vale,
tengo que ir al baño
demasiada cerveza
[Música] [
Música]
a
[Música  ]
salir
[Música]
sabes
oh
[Música]
oh sí [
Música]
es
[Música] [
Música]
a
[Música]
no, hoy es solo día libre bebé
uh [
Música]
entonces
[Música]
es
[  Aplausos]
nomiro moriaki
[Música]
es
extranjera [
Música]
es
extranjera en vivo
[Música]
hoy estamos aquí para honrar a aquellos que
han caído y han pagado el máximo
sacrificio,
incluidos aquellos que han muerto mientras estaban en
exilio que sirvió a esta gran nación
gerardo
presencia del ejército estadounidense
manuel castaño ejército estadounidense
presente presidente
[Música]
sí extranjero extranjero está
bien
[Música] está
bien [
Música]
uh [
Música] no
puedes pensar demasiado si algo
negativo está afectando tu vida,
no lo intentes  descúbrelo demasiado
porque te llevará a un mal lugar
[Música]
oh [
Música]
yosí,
solo estoy perdiendo el tiempo aquí
mis últimos sobrinos la última generación que
solía cuidar o jugar con
ellos ya están  uh, ya sabes, 23 años,
entonces sabes que incluso tienen hijos, pero
sus hijos no me conocen, no
me conocen en absoluto, así que sí, estás desapareciendo, por
supuesto,
y uh, ya sabes, y
como dije, no lo soy.  No soy vanidoso de ninguna
manera,
pero
me encantaba escuchar
a los niños decir no creado,
bueno, vendría cuando llegara allí.
Ellos no lo harán, nunca lo
haré, probablemente nunca volveré a escuchar eso
[Música]
hacer
[  Música]
entonces
[Música]
gracias
también lo
es
[Música]
desafortunadamente la solicitud no fue
aprobada
verifique con su banco y regrese y
hágalo de nuevo
[Música] [
Música]
hola no, quién es, soy Chris, lo
sé
[Música]  ¿
Cuántos años tienes ahora?
Tengo veintiún años. Por fin son las 10 de la mañana. ¿Cuándo es
tu turno? 21.
En junio. Está
bien.  como le dije a un hombre lluvioso uh,
realmente aprecio que me hayan enviado
ese dinero, vale, sí [
Música] está
bien
[Música]
adiós